como hemos visto las reacciones de
eliminación de dos tienen un mecanismo
de reacción concertado el carbono que
está directamente enlazado con el
halógeno se llama el carbono alfa y los
carbonos enlazados directamente con el
carbono alfa son los carbonos beta y
para que suceda la reacción de dos
necesitamos uno de estos protones beta
ahora el halógeno y el hidrógeno tienen
que estar en lados opuestos del enlace
que será el doble enlace si ponemos por
aquí nuestra línea punteada en la
dirección del enlace entre los carbonos
el halógeno y el hidrógeno tienen que
estar en lados opuestos y a eso le
llamamos anti además estos cuatro átomos
tienen que estar casi en el mismo plano
el hidrógeno el carbono
el otro carbono y el halógeno tienen que
estar casi en un mismo plano y por eso
decimos que tienen una geometría aplanar
y a todo eso junto le decimos anti peri
planar
de anti se refiere a que el halógeno y
el hidrógeno están en lados opuestos y
la parte de planar se refiere a que esos
cuatro átomos están casi en un mismo
plano en el mecanismo de reacción de dos
una base fuerte que por lo tanto tiene
una carga formal negativa la base fuerte
llega y se lleva a uno de nuestros
protones beta al mismo tiempo los
electrones de este enlace se mueven para
acá para formar un doble enlace y los
electrones del enlace con el grupo
saliente se van con el grupo saliente
así es que estos electrones de este
enlace se mueven para acá y ahora son
parte del doble enlace y así es como
formamos un al que no si estamos
pensando en la exterior selectividad de
un mecanismo de reacción de dos puede
ser muy útil ver a este mecanismo desde
otro punto de vista por ejemplo desde
una proyección de newman por acá tenemos
la proyección de newman de esta molécula
y podemos pensar en el mecanismo de
reacción
2 llega a una base fuerte y se lleva a
este protón de acá que es este mismo
protón de acá y entonces siguiendo
exactamente los mismos pasos los
electrones de este enlace se mueven para
quedar para formar un enlace doble y al
mismo tiempo los electrones de este
enlace se quedan en el halógeno y se van
y con esta proyección podemos ver que
estos cuatro átomos efectivamente están
en un mismo plano aunque también puede
ser útil verlo desde otro punto de vista
por aquí está el protón beta aquí está
uno de los carbonos el otro de los
carbonos y el halógeno nuestra base
fuerte llega y se lleva al protón beta
los electrones del enlace con el
hidrógeno beta se van para acá para
formar un doble enlace entre estos dos
carbonos y los electrones de este enlace
con el halógeno se van con el halógeno y
así es como se produce nuestro al que no
pero bueno ahora vamos a ver un ejemplo
en el que pensemos acerca de la exterior
actividad de un mecanismo de reacción de
dos digamos que tenemos este alumno de
alquilo y lo hacemos reaccionar connect
óxido de sodio electo csyd o de sodio es
una base fuerte no impedida
estéticamente este es el carbono alfa
estos carbonos enlazados directamente
con el carbono alfa son carbonos beta a
este le vamos a llamar beta 1 ya éste le
vamos a llamar beta 2 pero por el
momento vamos a ignorar al carbono beta
2 y nos vamos a concentrar en el beta 1
el cual tiene dos protones uno que se
acerca hacia nosotros y por eso lo
dibujamos con una cuña y otro que se
está alejando y lo dibujamos con una
línea punteada al protón que estamos
señalando con la cuña lo vamos a dibujar
de verde y el protón de la línea
punteada lo vamos a dibujar con blanco
pero lo que vamos a hacer aquí es ver a
través de éste
en la cee lo que estamos haciendo es una
proyección en la dirección del enlace
entre el carbono beta 1 y el carbono
alfa estamos viendo a través de este
enlace que se convierte en este punto si
ponemos nuestro ojo por acá y observamos
en esta dirección lo que obtenemos es
una proyección de newman el hidrógeno
verde quedaría arriba a la derecha por
acá el hidrógeno blanco queda arriba a
la izquierda por acá y el grupo metilo
queda hacia abajo y lo estamos dibujando
por acá ok no vamos a ver a profundidad
cómo se construye esta proyección de
newman porque ya las hemos visto en
otros vídeos pero el átomo de bromo se
encuentra abajo a la derecha queda por
acá este carbono también tiene un
hidrógeno que se aleja de la pantalla
hacia abajo
este hidrógeno y finalmente también
tenemos este grupo metilo que se
encuentra hacia arriba que es este grupo
metilo así es que aquí tenemos la
proyección de newman de esta molécula a
través de este enlace entre el carbono
alfa y el carbono beta 1 ahora si nos
fijamos en el hidrógeno y el átomo de
bromo están en lados opuestos y por acá
están los 2 carbonos entonces fácilmente
podemos decir que estos cuatro átomos se
encuentran en el mismo plano en este
plano que yo proyectado es una línea
recta por lo que podemos decir que son
anti peri planar es ahora por acá rote
un poquito la molécula y entonces aquí
tenemos también la proyección de newman
de esta molécula aquí está el hidrógeno
aquí está el bromo aquí están los dos
carbonos enlazados sobre los cuales
estamos haciendo la proyección y esto es
realmente lo mismo sólo que ahora la
línea recta que representa el plano
vertical pero son exactamente la misma
molécula y la misma proyección el
hidrógeno blanco es este el átomo de
bromo es este el hidrógeno verde terminó
por acá y también observa que los grupos
metilo también son anti porque están en
lados opuestos entonces en nuestro
mecanismo de reacción el 2 llega a una
base fuerte
y se lleva uno de nuestros protones beta
ahora en esta reacción nuestra base
fuerte es una unión de tóxico que llega
y se lleva a nuestro protón beta los
electrones de ese protón beta se mueven
al enlace entre los dos carbonos para
formar un enlace doble y al mismo tiempo
los electrones del enlace con el bromo
se van con el bromo y cuando esto sucede
cuando se forma el doble enlace estos
dos grupos metilo se terminan en lados
opuestos del doble enlace así es que lo
que esto nos da como producto es un al
que no trans pero bueno tal vez sea más
fácil ver esta reacción con una
proyección en perspectiva esta no es
otra conformación de esta molécula es
exactamente la misma solo que la estamos
viendo desde otro punto de vista nuestro
carbono alfa es este porque aquí está el
átomo de bromo entonces este es nuestro
carbono beta 1 por acá se encuentra el
beta 2
pero llega a una base fuerte y se lleva
este protón de acá los electrones de
este enlace se pasan para acá para
formar un doble enlace al mismo tiempo
que el bromo se va y ese es nuestro
mecanismo concertado que por cierto
cuando se forma el doble enlace estos
dos grupos metilo se terminan en lados
opuestos del doble enlace pero bueno
para que quede perfectamente claro vamos
a volver a ver esta reacción pero ahora
en un vídeo y en ese vídeo también vamos
a ver la otra conformación vamos a ver
qué producto obtenemos con esta reacción
si en lugar de tomar el hidrógeno blanco
tomáramos el hidrógeno verde que por
cierto en esta proyección el hidrógeno
blanco que estamos tomando en esta
reacción es éste
el hidrógeno verde es este tenemos aquí
nuestro alumno de alquilo con un
hidrógeno verde uno blanco y el bromo de
color rojo
vamos a observar esta molécula en la
dirección del enlace entre estos dos
carbonos entonces si queremos ver en la
carbonos si lo queremos ver como la
proyección de newman y observa que
cuando tenemos esta proyección de newman
si lo giramos un poquito podemos ver el
hidrógeno el carbono beta y el bromo en
una posición anti peri planar vertical y
observa que por acá tenemos estos otros
dos grupos metilo que están en su forma
anti bueno por acá estamos moviendo la
molécula para verlo con la proyección en
perspectiva y ahora pensemos que llega a
una base y se lleva este protón y se
forma este doble enlace y también vamos
a pretender que el átomo de bromo se fue
entonces lo que podemos ver aquí es que
los grupos metilo están en lados
opuestos del doble enlace
así es que este es el producto trans
pero si regresamos antes de que se
formará el doble enlace si regresamos a
nuestra proyección de newman como
tenemos un enlace simple entre esos dos
carbonos tenemos otra conformación
porque hay rotación sobre los enlaces
simples entonces podemos tener esta otra
conformación en la que es el hidrógeno
verde el que está en una posición anti
peri planner con el átomo de bromo y
entonces en esta conformación utilizando
esta proyección de newman podemos ver
que estos dos grupos metilo están cerca
están del mismo lado y entonces cuando
se forma el doble enlace cuando llega a
una base y se lleva a este hidrógeno
verde y el átomo de bromo se va los 2
grupos metilo están del mismo lado del
doble enlace y así es como obtenemos el
producto cis aquí está lo que estábamos
viendo en el vídeo esta es la proyección
de newman de la otra conformación
los dos grupos metilo están cerca el uno
del otro y por lo tanto tienen un efecto
gosh y se estan repeliendo por acá
tenemos el protón verde y el átomo de
bromo está por acá entonces cuando llega
a nuestra base fuerte el avión es tóxico
y se lleva a este protón los electrones
de este enlace se dan a formar un doble
enlace entre estos dos carbonos y estos
electrones se van con el bromo y los dos
grupos metilo se quedan del mismo lado
del enlace doble produciendo un al que
no sé si lo vemos desde otra perspectiva
por aquí tenemos nuestra base fuerte que
llega y se lleva a este protón que es el
protón verde y el bromo de color rojo se
encuentra por acá entonces cuando llega
a la base y se lleva a este protón los
electrones de este enlace se pasan para
acá para formar un doble enlace los
electrones de este enlace se dan con el
bromo y
los dos grupos metilo estos dos grupos
metilo se quedan del mismo lado del
enlace doble produciendo un producto cis
que vamos a dibujar por acá nos da como
producto un al que no que tiene sus dos
grupos metilo del mismo lado del enlace
doble bueno pero ahora pensemos en estas
dos con formaciones que tienen protones
anti peri plan ares con el átomo de
bromo en esta conformación el protón que
estaba en posición anti peri planar era
el hidrógeno blanco y en esta otra
conformación el protón que estaba en
posición anti peri planar es el
hidrógeno verde esta posición con el
hidrógeno blanco nos dio el producto
trans y la posición con el protón verde
nos dio el producto cis ahora algo que
sabemos muy bien es que esta
conformación es mucho más estable que la
otra porque aquí los grupos met y los
que son estorbosos están en posición
anti
mientras que en esta otra conformación
esos grupos metidos estorbosos están
cerca mutuamente por lo cual tienen un
efecto gota de repulsión que hace que
aumente el impedimento estético entonces
esta es una conformación mucho menos
estable y por lo tanto su producto el
producto six no es tan estable es menos
estable que nuestro producto trans aquí
lo que hice fue pasar en limpio nuestra
reacción tenemos aquí el mismo alumno de
alquilo la misma base y aquí están los
dos productos de esta reacción pero para
resumir lo que hicimos por aquí tenemos
el carbono beta 1 y este carbono tiene
dos protones uno que dibujamos de blanco
y el otro de verde dependiendo de cuál
de los dos protones se lleva a esta base
obtenemos dos productos distintos uno es
el producto trans y el otro es el
producto fish
el producto trans resulta hacer el
producto mayoritario porque proviene de
la conformación más estable mientras que
el producto 6 es el producto minoritario
porque proviene de la conformación menos
estable y entonces decimos que esta es
una reacción estéreo selectiva porque
tenemos estos dos estéreo isómeros como
productos y uno de ellos es favorecido
producimos una mayor cantidad de uno de
ellos
en este caso producimos más al que nos
trans y menos al que nos cis y por eso
decimos que la reacción es exterior
selectiva ahora hay un detalle más
durante todo este vídeo hemos ignorado
al carbono beta 2 que tiene varios
protones que son muy fáciles de colocar
en una posición anti peri planear con el
átomo de bromo así es que por acá vamos
a dibujarlo aquí tenemos uno de los
protones del carbono beta 2
y por acá tenemos el átomo de bromo
llega a nuestra base fuerte nuestro año
net óxido y se lleva uno de los protones
del carbono beta 2 estos electrones se
mueven para que los electrones de este
enlace se van con el bromo y entonces
obtenemos otro producto los electrones
de este enlace se pasaron para acá y
ahora forman este doble enlace y listo
este es el producto que obtenemos si la
base se lleva a uno de los protones del
carbono beta 2 durante todo el vídeo nos
enfocamos en los productos que obtenemos
y la base se lleva a algunos de los
protones del carbono beta 1 porque con
ellos podemos ver la diferencia estética
aquí se puede ver muy fácil la stereo
selectividad de la reacción pero nunca
se nos debe de olvidar que puede haber
más de un carbono beta y entonces
también tenemos otros productos